So now that we have learned how to do this,
let's start applying it to doing filtering on averaging for images.
I'm going to show this simple example using the classic image of peppers
showing a black and white image, 5 by 12, 512 by 512 image resolution.
I'm going to apply a average filter.
Now this time around I'm not going to apply a 3 by 3 but
a 21 by 21 neighborhood kernel, okay?
So that's important to note.
That we've been playing around with just 3 by 3's but these can be quite big.
And that's one of the things I want to show you here.
This is a 5 by 12, 512 by 512 image and
I'm going to apply a kernel that's 21 by 21.
This is the output of that process.
basically, if you notice, the whole image is quite blurry.
What has happened really is, at each and
every point we've basically replaced the value by the average of
the neighborhood in a 12 by 12, 21 by 21 neighborhood.
Now all of a sudden, if you notice, all the sharp edges are gone.
Remember when we looked at images in the histograms and stuff like that?
There are lots of peaks and valleys in these types of images.
Well by blurring it, using a filter,
we've gotten rid of a whole lot of really sharp peaks next to each other.
Therefore, this image now looks a little blurred.
Also notice the edges.
This is what I was referring to earlier because what we're doing is
we're adding information.
Some of the information will be lost, and in this case to do a 21 by 21,
but 10 pixels were added on all three sides, and
of course the average of this does degrade information at the edges.
Just to showcase this, the box filter basically if you were to look at it
in the same height map configuration we've looked at,
would just be a flat box like this and it'd have a shape and again in the image
form of the same values across the whole sub-image that we have.
Again this is a 21 by 21.
The intensity is the same for each and every one of them.
In this case I would assume would be, you know, 1 over 1 over 21,
and this would be my kind of the kernel, what it would look like.